you never know what's gonna happen in
the ozarks wait you haven't seen ozark
yet we're giving you the inside scoop of
what makes an award-winning tv show
let's take a dive into some behind the
scenes of ozark number one an ozarkian's
greatest fear is other people trying to
get rid of you right
well
not exactly ruth's
actress julia garner's fear became true
when she was scripted to pick up a mouse
she put up a fight that's for sure
thinking about it just makes me cringe
after all the panic attacks and
resistance from garner the crew decided
it was best to just throw in a hand
double glad to see that came in handy
number two show creators decided it was
best to bring the ozarks down south for
the winter what drew you here
well the work most of what we see on
screen is actually recreated at
locations in sound stages in georgia
creator bill dubuque took early
inspiration from the ozarks when he
would visit there as a team the generous
tax breaks and beautiful scenery were
enough to convince the production to
make the move though such a move can
prove to be pretty risky that's why
bateman became nitpicky with avoiding
all georgia made aspects production
designer david bomba had to work out the
puzzle from the very start that was
exciting to kind of be
my
part of ozark and the cast agreed who
wouldn't want to work on the beautiful
lakes of georgia
at least in real life that is
number three welcome to the dark side
what it can be hard to look at some of
the darker lit scenes of ozark so turn
up the brightness on your tv because
it's all meant to pull you into the
character's gloomy world here's what
cinematographer ben cutchens had to say
about it
there's a grittiness to it and a little
bit of an earthy quality that i think
fits the show lighting wasn't the only
thing that was added for effect in fact
many subtle changes in post were added
to fit the crime drama setting from pain
on the walls to big background
transformations we got to wonder how
expensive it was for them to just film
in the actual ozarks
number four we feel so blue just
thinking about the characters on ozark
i didn't know what to do
apparently that's the whole point
bateman and cutchens both wanted to give
the show a deeper meaning and a distinct
look its grittiness and slight touch to
each scene makes a sneakily want to feel
what each character is feeling isn't the
idea that if you want to get away with
something you don't tell anyone and they
thought we wouldn't notice
you never really know what's lurking in
the shadows
yikes
number five it takes a lot of time and
dedication to get an accent down for a
roll the cast put in the work and it
definitely showed i had a lot of work to
do so i needed to hunker down they
certainly did no one said it was easy
when you come from other areas with
different accents it means more and more
work coming from new york i wasn't
really familiar with that so that world
number six
there's no flying ninjas or superhumans
in the ozarks but the stunts were pretty
great
are reminded episode after episode of
the intense action that plays on in the
gritty town in this series it looks like
most of the action was done
professionally
with a touch of visual effects we're
happy to know that all the actors
involved had stunned people to take the
hits
whoa that's gotta hurt
number seven
secrecy is key when it comes to a hit
television show's success
and sometimes cast and crew are tempted
to give a little hint it's definitely
heavier this season oh great
the fears of even one photo being
snapped was enough for producers to
crack down on leaks that's why no phones
were allowed on set at any time
that means you jason
leaks are at the top of the list of
onset rules but respect for your fellow
actors follows close i like i like that
jason bateman guy
you wouldn't convincingly love the
character of another actor who talks
smack about you after the scene ends
right nice people get along and we've
got a whole set full of them there
that's just bad work ethics and it's not
welcome would you like a five a a five
season contract or a two-seater
number eight
showing up to work every day on a series
year after year you make a lot of
friends
and lose a couple to the show's demise
try not to get the audience into the
weeds too much with that unfortunately
when you become a part of the ozark
family you never know when your time is
up it's best to not get attached to any
of your favorite characters especially
with season one being so relentless and
taking so many of them yeah that's not
fun that's the one thing that's really
that's not fun
number nine ozark season four began its
filming a year after the start of the
pandemic not the best timing but show
creators wanted the show to go on let's
just wing this extra precautions were
taken as bateman announced he would step
down as director for the first two
episodes to keep his fellow co-stars
safe and working with these precautions
producers had to create a comfortable
atmosphere for the cast and crew it
didn't seem to affect their work in any
way
the producer side of me made me think
it's just not responsible to have one of
the actors direct the first two
number 10 working close with your fellow
castmates day in and day out year after
year can create long lasting friendships
the cruise the cast the locations it's a
peach and for the cast of ozark they
created one big circle of friendships
it drove them crazy thinking that they
could be next in leaving the show i have
so much fun playing this role so i like
yeah keep her alive
they certainly found a method to the
madness
number 11 out of the bunch of stars
listed on the show it's well known that
jason bateman and laura linney are
household names oh it's going to be that
kind of show as opposed to this kind of
show both garnered dozens of awards
throughout their careers and helped earn
the show 32 primetime emmy nominations
including best director for bateman that
is something but stars are made and
co-star julia garner was able to snack
herself two prime time emmys for best
supporting actress back to back
bateman and the rest of the cast
certainly have time to catch up to her
with one more season to garner another
award number 12. ozark showrunner jason
bateman had to take on a lot with
directing himself and his co-stars i
wanted to direct a 600 page movie well
it certainly was more than 600 pages the
daunting task of filling those big shoes
really didn't seem to phase him though
it's not uncommon for actors to direct
themselves in film and tv but bateman
wanted to take full control of his
performance and stay out of his head on
set
we wonder if he yelled at himself for
not remembering his lines it changed the
way in which i performed the character
because i knew i would just be noting
myself but what did the other stars on
the show have to say about that
certainly only good things from
award-winning actress laura linney which
we could be sure means a lot he's not
just a good director he's a really
really really good director number 13
what if leeds bateman and linny turned
down the roles they actually almost did
you know about this
it was reported that bateman wanted to
steer clear of acting and just direct we
guess he couldn't resist
and neither could lenny all thanks to
him
i wasn't looking to do a series but i've
always really really admired jason
bateman well that was a lot we're
looking forward to the final installment
of ozark and predicting who's next
hopefully this season is not one filled
with rats and tragedy
wrong
what are you looking forward to in the
final season